wait they just give you the rarest skin
in the game did you ever wonder what
would happen if you bought every single
League skin well our very own video
editor Sam Gore found out recently
basically since your shop can't give you
an offer Riot support will hook you up
with one of these rare limited skins the
first time that your empty shop appears
my shop came around and it said I had no
skins available to purchase and so I had
seen online that somebody had reached
out and obtained the option to pick six
very rare skins including the Pax
Twisted Fate skin Sam got Pax Twisted
Fate worth probably at least two
thousand dollars on its own it was given
away to the first 20 000 attendees at
Pax 2009 so there aren't exactly that
many in the wild sheesh is that the
rarest skin in the game
um yes yes it is but when we asked
exactly how many counts had all
purchasable skins well they wouldn't
tell us